it's supposed to be a movie showing
camera explosion but it's not working so
it doesn't matter so um uh my board rate
is going to drop by a factor of two
so i have half the number of slides for
the second one
um what i want to do then is try to
explain um the cambrian explosion which
is i'll explain what that is in a moment
and then try to look at how one might
explain it but in the back of your minds
think about how one might explain any of
the major transitions in the evolution
of life
and
so um
so
what's the cambrian explosion so we're
now dealing exclusively with animals so
not plants not fungi not any of the
other 24 plus independent origins of
multicellularity and the animal phyla
there are about 30 of them come in three
flavors
the first one are the sponges
and the sponges have no organized
tissues or organs some sponges you can
put them in a blender and the cells
reassemble themselves into an adult
again
so there are animals but they are
organized like most
then there are a couple of filer
jellyfish corals
called diploblasts and they called
diploblast because they have two
primary cell layers during embryogenesis
and inside and outside the ectoderm and
the endoderm and so those are those guys
and then all of the other phyla
are called triploblasts they have three
primary cell layers the inside the
ectoderm makes the gut the outside the
ectoderm makes the outside and the
mesoderm makes things like
heart bone a lot of the tissues
and so they're often called bilaterians
because they tend to be bilaterally
symmetrical
and so the cameron explosion is largely
about the
sudden appearance of the triploblastic
phyla
at the base of the cambrian
and so here's just a bunch of
triploblasts
okay
so naive expectation this is from uh
darwin's origin of species that monty
showed uh yesterday
and so
you can just count diversity of lineages
through time to
etc
and if you
measure a sort of disparity sort of the
the morphological difference the
phenotypic difference between things so
a jellyfish is searched in a human
there's only three species but they're
really disparate but 10 000 species of
beetle all look like 10 000 species of
beetles so the disparity is really low
on this graph here the way darwin's
drawn it disparity just grows steadily
as a function of time
so a naive interpret
expectation for the history of life
prior to the fossil record
would be that as time proceeds species
progressively become more and more
different from each other and maximum
disparity should be now
so
if we take the fundamental animal body
plans what we find is something quite
different so this is the present
this is the beginning of the cambrian
about 542 million years ago
this is
diversity of life in the oceans
measured from the fossil record so
there's the end cretaceous mass
extinction for example
and what we find is the number of
readily fossilized phyla basically
emerge entirely within the cambrian or
slightly before with one exception
so the sudden appearance of the major
body organizations of animals occur
during the cayman explosion
so here's a diagram now i'm going to
spend a little bit of time with so
here's the pre-cambrian cambrian
boundary at 542 543 million years ago
this is the cambrian so my diagram
stopping here at 490 million years ago
so this is about what about 50 million
years
and this is going down to about 590
million years
this is diversity as a function of time
so number of genera a proxy for species
so it actually accelerates and then
plateaus
so there's the acceleration and then
plateauing and then something else
happens in the ordovician which i'm not
going to talk about
and this is the number of classes within
the fire so phylum mollusca has about
what is it about eight or nine classes
the clams the snails the cephalopods and
a bunch of other things
and so that plateaus quite quickly
rises and then plateaus quite quickly
so let's look at the fossil record of
the precursor stages through the
cambrian explosion so
animal fossils start about 580 million
years ago as i said before ignoring the
biomarkers of sponges
and a spectacular uh formation in china
where there are fossil embryos
so early embryos have a hard membrane
around them that makes them preservable
they lose it quite quickly rudy raff's
shown this really nicely and of course
for the most part you have no idea what
they belong to because there's only a
few cells there so you can't tell what
phylum they belong to but they look like
animal
except for the baseball i don't know
what that's about
okay so fossil embryos was really really
nice early on
and then starting also at about 580
there is something called the ediacaran
boat biota which is again named after an
australian locality ediacara in south
australia
we don't understand their biology very
well and so we don't know how to count
classes in general
so here's just a slice of these things
this thing has been argued to be related
to jellyfish
we don't know whether this is sort of is
that the front and the back or is it
stuck in the ground dangling in the
water column
don't know this thing it looks like it's
got a frontish in a backish in some sort
of cereation the segments if that's what
they are seem to be slightly off
out of phase with each other which is
kind of interesting
and so they could be early animals they
could be giant protists single cell
eukaryotes with
multinucleate they could be an
independent invention a multicellularity
that's gone extinct some people have
claimed that there are lichens some
argue that they're a fungi
we don't really know
and so when i've been thinking about the
camera explosion i have in the back of
my mind the fact that i'm not going to
work out what these things are most
paleontologists don't feel they can
proceed until they identify what the
taxes are which has sort of frozen that
for quite some time
so ediacaran ecosystems look like they
consist of fairly simple filter feeders
living off the embryonic stages of these
things and it also looks like there were
extensive bacterial mats on the
substrate on the bottom
and the sediments at that time have this
classic thing called elephant hide
texture
it looks like this it's stiff the
bacteria have glued it together
okay so that's the ediacaran biota and
pretty much they go extinct at the
pre-cambrian cambrian boundary
so the next two appear and this is
really really important uh trace fossils
which is tracks and trails of organisms
and that starts at about 555 million
years ago and initially they're only
horizontal
and then precisely at the precambrian
cambrian boundary they go vertical
and the argument is the argument is that
you can't burrow unless you have a
celome
and the only things that have cell ohms
are the triploblasts
so the argument is
that this thing must indicate the origin
of
uh triple blastic animals
and that this thing
may have had a sealant that may not have
had a silo
so even though we can't tell the
identity of the organisms
the trace foster record gives us some
indication of what the underlying
biology was like
and so this is uh
the first occurrence of this is a
betting plane of rock
and it looks like it's going down and up
and down and up and down and up so
penetrating
backwards and forwards and if you slice
it through you can see that and this is
sauron jensen working in spain now but
from sweden
who's the world's best at interpreting
these things now i made a strange
statement i said um
this occurs precisely at the
pre-cambrian cambrian boundary which is
kind of a
dramatic claim for a fossil record
that's really rich and the reason why i
can say precisely is because the first
appearance of this fossil in
newfoundland defines the bait of the
cambrian
and then someone probably found an older
one in south australia so it's kind of
annoying
okay so it's really interesting so it's
penetrating the sediment for the first
time about 542 million years ago
and then slightly later we start to get
the first skeletonized fossils so these
things are not skeletonized they're
stiff but they have no skeletons
and so i'm not going to show you
due to time the first lightly
bi-mineralized ones but i'm going to
show you the small shelly fossils
so these are the small shelly fossils
and they're called that because they're
small and they're shelly and their
fossils
which is a fancy way of saying we really
know who they belong to
except the thought is that some of them
probably are parts of much larger
organisms
these are often typically you know 200
microns across or something and some
fossils have been found with them all
knit together
in some sort of armored worms
um
okay so that gets us now
into the early cambrian
and then we have something called the
chen jiang biota i apologize for the
pronunciation and the first body fossils
are things like trilobites
so it's some distance into the cambrian
and then slightly later we have the
burger shale who's heard of the burger
shale
right so the burger shale biota
is sitting here at about 510 or so it's
really not properly dated yet
and from my point of view the burgess
shale is really in the warm afterglow of
the cayman explosion
the fire are apparent the classes that
are going to originate in the cambrian
have originated
diversity is plateaued so we're seeing
the stable world in the marine realm
after the cambrian explosion
and so here's a beautiful book you can
buy uh with the chen jiang fossils and
it's incredible stuff i think it's 17
fighter now 100 plus animal species
spectacular preservation from things
like trilobites the first chordates
uh sponges all sorts of things
incredible stuff
um
and then there's the famous burger shale
where the preservation is as spectacular
but it's gray on grey which makes it
harder to look at
so the famous opania with five eyes and
a trunk
lots of marellas with gut content
squished out
so found up here by walcott and things
we don't know quite what they are
lucinia
named by simon conway morris based on
something that he saw while taking
a substance that has ds and l in it
yeah that's right if you're a bit
dyslexia dyslexic
so um so here's a reconstruction of that
burger shale
biota
servicing the ratio of soft-bodied to
skeletonized taxes about the same as in
modern marine environments which is
interesting so we think we've got most
of the species which is really pretty
nice
so a foil for this lecture i'm going to
pick on the deceased steve gould
so gould emphasized the weirdness of
these fossils he hinted that a special
genetic mechanism might be at work to
create the failure
and he argues in his book you know our
wonderful life if we could rerun the
tape of life we would see an utterly
different biota from today's
and i'm going to argue that these things
are almost certainly not true but that's
by foil and he isn't here to defend
himself
so there's hallucigenia a failed early
experiment with steve's argument there's
the reconstruction
uh
turns out
that
it's got structures that look like
they're homologs with something found in
chenjiang
and so it looks like uh simon comoros
got the damn thing upside down
walking on spines doesn't make much
sense and they missed a row of these
things and so it looks like it's an
ecofriend which is a basal arthropod
and so most of the problematic fossils
have been assigned i think fairly
comfortably to existing phylum there are
a few that still stand out but it isn't
20 or 30 the way steve gould argued it's
just one or two or three out of 30.
so they're not that weird but a lot of
them are what we call stem groups
archaeopteryx is a bird but it's got a
long tail it's got teeth it's got claws
on its fingers
a lot of these
things belong to existing filer but they
don't fit into the current living groups
so they are intermediate in that sense
okay so what i'm going to do now is i'm
going to simplify this and talk now as
if
there's no anatomy there's sort of a
a pre-cambrian explosion time and a post
time just for convenience but there
really is an anatomy and unfolding of
the event
and i like to argue that you wouldn't
call it the cambrian explosion if we
were sentient clams say living 490
million years ago because most of our
fossil record would be dominated by the
change and so i think we'd call it
rather than the cambrian explosion we
would call it the great unfolding
right and so that anatomy is in order 10
million years which is fairly
interesting
so again burgess shale trilobites with
the soft appendages preserved
so what needs explaining the literature
is complex in part because people
haven't dissected out the different
things there's the increase in disparity
the animal filer there's the increase in
diversity there's the time of onset why
did it occur roughly half a billion
years ago why not two billion years ago
why not 10 million years ago
why is the duration order 10 million
years not 1 million years why 100
million years in fact general why is it
that i can trace major transitions in
the fossil record if evolution went 10
or 100 times faster i wouldn't see it
mammals would just appear life would
have invaded land
if it's much slower then i wouldn't have
many of them so i think it's incredibly
interesting that that time scale and why
is the explosion unique
causes of the explosion
um
environmental changes are often posited
increased oxygen is thought to have
played a a necessary but not sufficient
role
to be an animal you've got to have
reasonable levels of oxygen and it looks
like oxygen may have started to jump up
about 600 million years ago maybe tied
to the snowball earth's
so i suspect that's necessary but not
sufficient but maybe that's what
occurred half a billion years ago if
oxygen had jumped up a billion years
earlier we might have had some and it
came an explosion
developments you can't make animals
until you have the genes for making
animals
and so clearly new developmental system
has to be developed and then things like
ecology and i'm gonna in the well you'll
see what i'm gonna do so almost played a
role what's the interplay between the
factors
so jim valentine is here has argued for
an ecological view and what he has is
sort of arbitrary niches where each
square represents a novel a new way of
being
and then what he does he has a jump size
where genetically it's hard to produce
new phyla but relatively easy to produce
new species or genera
and then what he says is surrounding
niche space must be free for large jumps
to succeed
so it's hard for a new bird to come into
existence if there are lots of birds
already around um
and so then when he does i'm just
simulating it here you know small jumps
there's a big jump with a new phylum
some
new class
another new class mostly new
genre
and then here's a big jump that should
be a new phylum but it's already got
competitors ecologically so it doesn't
take
and so if you run this a little bit
further
there's two phyla each with two classes
and most of the ecological space is
filled
now at the end permian a quarter of a
billion years ago about 96 98 of war
species in the marine realm went extinct
but we don't see new fire don't even see
much delay new classes and the argument
is even though diversity is plummeted
most of the major ecological types are
still there there are some sharks there
are some still sea urchins there are
still things
so this is the argument that ecological
incumbency limits innovation
so developmental genetics origin of new
developmental system is responsible for
cambrian explosion morphologically
simple morphologically
complex development of the
origin of the new genes there is
responsible
how can we know what the
developmental capacity of the last
common ancestor of all the say triple
blasts were
well you can
take a fish genome and you can take a
fly genome and you can look for genes in
common and it turns out that any gene in
common turns out to be in the last
common ancestor of all the triple blasts
so phytogenetic analysis of model
systems means we can actually make a
fairly good guess as to what the set of
genes were at the time of the origin of
the triploblast
and that's enormously valuable
because we don't have any fossils from
most of these lineages here so we're
really stuck so comparative genomics has
made an enormous difference to this
discipline
so what are the genes are the hox genes
they just remind you things like whole
tears
here on the third thoracic segment and
if you take this gene ultra both by
thorax and you knock it out you get a
nobel prize
you had a fly instead of having two
wings and the whole tails you get four
wings so presumably most of you have
heard of this but it shows you a little
bit of development right the way
development operates
what's happened was by knocking out
ultra by thorax you've changed the
identity of the third thyroid thoracic
segment to the identity of the second
which is really interesting as you
haven't actually changed wings and
halters into wings at all
um
and so those are ubiquitous across all
the animals vertebrates are weird
because we've had two genome
duplications since we've diverged
and then things like you know eyeless
you know you express the gene in the
right place you can get eyes instead of
antennae or eye on a wing or eye on a
leg
or eye on another antenna so just and it
turns out that you know to me this is
staggering this this next result is
eyeless turns out to have homologs
across all the phyla
and so i think this this incredible
result here you can take
the mouse
homolog or one of them and stick it in a
fly
and the fly recognizes it
and builds an eye and to me that's
unbelievable right because at least a
billion years of evolution a billion
years of evolution 500 down the fly
lineage and 500 up the the chordate the
vertebrate lineage
and yet the amino acid sequence is so
conserved that drosophila can recognize
it and switch on the genes responsible
for making eyes
um and so i think we'll see the
stabilizing selection is a dominant
feature of a lot of animal evolution
and i think that's a really good example
of that
um
so there are a whole bunch of genes in
common the hox genes for anterior
posterior patterning it's still involved
in the eye oh oh oh yeah yeah
that gene is involved in in mollusks
vertebrates
yeah the pac-6 is involved yeah yes in
that sense yes it's it's involved in
initiating initiating development of the
eye
but the eyes are completely different of
course but they're initiating which says
the last common ancestor had a
photoresist photoreceptor and that
photoreceptor is turned on by pac-6 or
eyeless
yeah so i misunderstood i thought you're
asking what the mutant phenotypes look
like
so
um
so the genes are dorsal ventral so
there's genes for making the cartesian
coordinates the animal body plane so
development you've got to create the
space so you create the space with the
hox genes dorsal ventral left right and
then regionalizing it regionalizing the
nervous system regionalizing the gut
growing things out or in distillers
photoreception pack six
tin man tin man does what nobody know
makes you a heart right so drosophila
people have a sense of humor right
wizard of oz
had no heart tin man
um
okay so that's sort of some of the tool
kit
to suggest that all those genes lie
between here and here which makes sense
what i'm going to argue is i don't think
it's true
and so
that's what i'm going to do now
so
this is a phrase principle of
frustration i've sort of taken it from
stuart kaufman who stole it from the
spin glass people you've got you know a
lattice with something spin up and
something spin down and you put one in
the middle it doesn't know which way to
which way to spin
so the same idea is that different
ecological needs will often have
partially conflicting solutions so that
the overall optimal design of an
organism will rarely be optimal for any
of the specific tasks that need to
perform there are trade-offs
but i say that i think trade-offs is
critical to understanding the cambridge
explosion and innovation
and so now one of the nice things is i'm
going to jump from the fossil record to
computer simulation and the virtual
computer simulation is you can explore
the entire phase space rather than
having just one realization of the
process what we see today in the fossil
record
and so what carl nicholas did
at cornell a long time ago
is developed a
sixth morphogenetic rule system for
plants
so there's probably probability of
branching on the left and the right and
then there's the angles that those
branches emerge
and then these
dots here are the tops of these branches
here
so there's the angles in this direction
so probability of branching and then the
angles and then the angles so it's six
developmental rules really really simple
so then you can perform evolution on it
variation followed by selection you can
change the values of these a little bit
make a new plant and then ask how well
does that plant perform given tasks
so here's a three-dimensional
representation of that 60 space he
picked parameter values that gave the
morphology of cook sonia that i showed
last lecture
and then varied that a little bit
increasing the branching probabilities
and then wandered it through until it
settled down on an optimum
so the nice
i'll do it now and so the nice thing is
you can actually quantitatively write
down what's being optimized so you can
actually measure fitness
so the first thing you optimize was
reproductive success
seeds occur on the ends of branches
and so reproductive success has two
components which is the number of branch
tips
and then he also has the dispersal
component to it the higher the branches
the better dispersal
and so it produces one optimal solution
that looks like an upside down broom and
not much like a plant
so then he did it again starting with
cooksonia
this guy here sees and said let's do it
for
light interception
sun rises and it sets
and so you just look at the maximum
light interception if there's multiple
tiers you want to avoid overshadowing
three optimal solutions
and some of them look like plants
and the last thing he did is he
optimized mechanical stability
long branches that better be vertical if
they're horizontal they'll break off and
that is a bad thing
okay so then the question so then
evolution under simple selective regimes
fupta
simple morphologies so then it said what
happens now if i select for all three
simultaneously
and now trade-offs frustration sets in i
can't both be optimal for reproductive
success and for lighter deception
so when you select for three
simultaneously
seven solutions with more complex
morphologies
and then what he did is he added in a
fourth need minimizing surface area
desiccation is a problem for anything
that lives on land so that's minimizing
surface area
and now they're about 20 or 21 optimal
solutions
now the thing that i found staggering
about this is there is no fundamental
change in the developmental program none
zero zip
it's got the same six rules
but as you increase the number of
selective pressures the number of
optimal solutions and their complexity
goes up
so to me the cambridge explosion is not
about
fundamentally the invention of the
planetary and developmental system
it's about the capacity to extract the
combinatorial potential out of that
system and you can only do that
ecologically
and i like to skate out on thin ice and
therefore make errors
in fact michael nutman the audience
pointed out my argument for the lunar
cycle still in females is sort of bogus
because uh
in most female mammals it isn't even
vaguely a month like mice it's three
days etc so
ah
okay
most of these morphologies appear in the
fossil record by the end of the devonian
when the first forest emerge
so at some really simple level with six
developmental rules and four selective
pressures
nicholas has been able to mimic plant
evolution as we see in the fossil record
now there's no leaves there's no roots
there's no
flowers and no reproductive organs but
that's a staggering result
so the way i've been thinking about this
is in terms of fitness landscapes which
uh monty talked about as well yesterday
so these are the developmental rules
this is just two out of the six
so to my mind this captures sort of the
variation part of darwin's evolution
each point corresponds to a specific
morphology so a population will have a
range of morphologies and then i've left
the z-axis for fitness the probability
of survival so this is sort of the
variation followed by selection the
darwinian two-step so here i can pick up
that and so any given morphology in a
given environment will have a specific
fitness
and so you can map out all of them and
you get a fitness landscape
and so then you've got the number of
optima that you expect to see on the
fitness landscape and so
the fitness landscape roughens as the
number of frustrated needs increases
and i've dropped the height to the peak
here because the trade-offs means that
an absolute sense the fitness has
dropped if that has any meaning since
the environment is different
so expect diversity and disparity
increases evolution explores the
landscape
so one thing which i think is a huge
challenge and a possible critique of
this approach is there's a again
a morphogenetic fitness landscape so
it's not a rightie in landscape which is
allelic
it's based on the morphogenetic rules
so there's genes and their alleles and
the genes are organized into gene
networks those gene networks conspire to
produce sort of a capacity to produce
morphology and so i think one of the big
challenges is trying to work out how to
go from this wealth of information in
here to understanding the relatively few
morphogenic rules that i think are
responsible for organizing
either plants or animals or fungi etc
so the dimensionality drops as you go up
in this direction which has bearing on
gabrielettes arguments for holy fitness
landscapes
um it makes understanding how one moves
from genotypic space into a morphogenic
space difficult as lewinton has pointed
out as early as 1974. 1974
but i think the morphogenetic rules is
the thing that really matters because
it's the morphology that the selection
is operating on
so then we come back to the ediacarans
and so so
yeah there could be
tons of peaks out there that are really
far away genetically so they're
irrelevant
yeah i mean it's the mapping is hard how
you move
um and there's lots of aspects of the
phenotype so
so now coming back to the cambrian
explosion having sort of set that up and
so one thing that struck me about these
things is no one knows what they are
um
as you know darwin did really well not
knowing the nature of the predatory
material so the question is can i make
some progress understand the camera
explosion without knowing what these
things are biologically and i must
confess i don't find these very
interesting and the reason why i don't
find it very interesting is that i'm
sort of a complexity addict so
vertebrate skeletons full rig sailing
ships chess
and these things just aren't
particularly complex they don't have any
knobs and bobs on them and then it
suddenly occurred to me they don't have
any knobs and bobs on them
animals today are defined by their knobs
and bobs evolution red in tooth and claw
no teeth no claws no macroscopic sense
organs no antennae no ct
there are no organs of interaction
on these things for thing with to
interact with things of a similar size
there are no bite marks there's no claw
claws there's no armor
they basically lack organs of
interaction
and so i think what's happening then is
that these things if we look at the
phytogenetic distribution of
developmental genes have the genes
that basically um are shared between all
living fire today but they don't have
the morphology
and so i think what happens uh for the
across the cambrian explosion transition
is we start to invent adult body adult
body ecology and i don't know how that
happens but basically all these beef
steaks sitting on the seafloor and
somebody works out that their food
and then the arms race begins
and i just want to remind you that
biological interactions are vast in
ecosystems so this is a food web from
one lake in wisconsin this is a
simplified food web of the north
atlantic
i think it's homo sapiens we've made
ourselves largely immune to most of
these interactions
so i don't think we realize just how
many selective pressures most species
actually
have most of the time
and so i think what happens then
here's the nicholas equivalent and
here's the cayman explosion equivalent
simple morphologies for simple needs
and then you increase the number of
selective pressures via ecological
interaction the landscape roughens
and you go from ediacaran times to
cambrian times
so how does one test this so one test is
to dive into the genomic data
and so let's do that a little bit so
this is an interesting graph from
towson's group in germany
but what he has is the phytogenetic time
of origin of drosophila melanogasted
genes
so this is the present as she goes down
the tree
and so what you can see here
sorry yeah
you still have exponential growth
i mean exponential
you know
reproduction right yeah so each species
is competing with itself as well yes so
how can we
so so there's this assumption that
there is no complication between them
there's no armor there's no clause
there's no
well if
if you don't have any organs to
if you don't have any claws
or jaws or biting parts then
you can't eat your fellow species
yes the bacterial mats yes they're still
competition they're still ecology
they're still feeding on the bacterial
maps they're still sucking out larval
forms out of the water column yeah so
there's still ecology going on
but they're not interacting with oh so
they're interacting indirectly but
they're not they're not predating on
each other
yeah yeah so i mean how does your whole
picture of the you know morphogenetic
rules sort of
you know
encompass that because
so what it tells me so let's go here so
let's do this diagram here so so one
thing that's always bothered me a little
bit with sort of the sean carroll
approach to this the key gene approach
is that you only find conserved genes if
they're conserved you don't know whether
there's a whole bunch of genes that are
not conserved that are phylum specific
and so this is a whole genome approach
he said let's have a look at drosophilas
all of drosophila genes and ask where on
the tree of life do they originate and
what's been left off here is the huge
number of genes that occur
in the last common ancestor of all
cellular organisms the robust sum of rna
is the elongation factors etc the trnas
and so on this tree here this is when
the phylum arthropodas established
and what you can see that in drosophila
they're not many genes that date to this
particular time
but tells you that they're virtually no
arthropod-specific genes
so when i was an undergraduate we were
very much built that each phylum has a
fundamentally different body plan and
therefore had a fundamentally different
set of genes
and then the camera explosion is really
hard to explain because you've got to 30
times invent a unique set of genes
independently
but here the peak of innovation
is at about the byterion stage or the
umedazowin stage which includes the
jellyfish and the corals
so there's a big burst of innovation
starting
the sponges through the jellyfish stage
and then
it looks like given that genomic
potential then they differentiate into
the filer
so massive pre-adaptation in the genome
now one thing that occurs to me about
this in terms of gene genetic evolution
in here is that even
unicellular organisms like commando
flagellates live in a multi-cellular
world right
they've got to find mates they've got to
avoid predators they've got to find food
so all the
signal transduction pathways etc need to
be in place already so that i can work
out how to modify my cytoskeletons so i
can decide whether to reproduce or
ingest something or to run away
so a lot of the key genes that occur in
us obligate metazoans evolved in
non-obligate eukaryotes because they're
still in a multicellular world they're
just
obligatedly so
um
so i think then so so this then supports
the argument that there's a
developmental system that does not
express morphological complexity yet
because it wasn't challenged to do so
yet yeah it still looks like there was
an explosion of development
yeah and it does seem to be sitting in
here
yeah it's a good question and so i don't
know enough about so it has to happen in
the world of protists
most for the most part or the beginning
of multicellular organisms there is a
burst the other issue with this diagram
which is tough is you work out where you
are by finding the gene and other taxa
and so we haven't sampled the genomes of
protists all that well so as we do so
some of these genes may finish up
appearing earlier than that so there's a
selection bias a little bit in the sense
that we haven't
you know the this is the fungi plant
split this is the eukaryotic split so
there's no dissection on that part of
the tree of life
or something else
to me most i don't know gene duplication
strikes me as being particularly
important for the innovation of eugenes
i know a partial gene conversion does it
mutation i don't think
can't do it because it's just too slow
most genes
aren't separated by each other by just a
few mutations right by a few amino acids
okay so then i think the developmental
system originates here
and the camera explosion was driven by
the onset of adult adult
ecological interactions with a
concomitant increase in the number of
frustrated needs
so environmental conditions had to be in
place yeah with respect to the tout
scrap
how i listened carefully but how how do
we know there wasn't just a bunch of
of organisms already out there in that
earlier period besides the idea cara
that just haven't left any fossils
yeah so you get this nasty problem
how do we know that there are a whole
bunch of myoformal you know
20 30 50 micron organism level triple
blasts out there in the water column
yeah well are just soft very soft things
that don't leave any yeah like like a
lot of phyla
um so the answer is we don't
is the bottom line so you concentrate on
the skeletonized things or the tips
tough things molecular clocks tend to
give rough concordance of these time
frames which include obviously the soft
body things to live today the trace
fossil record is fairly important
because you know there's before 555
million years there are no traces
none
so if 800 million years ago there were
30 filer but they were microscopic then
some of them you think would have worked
they had to disturb the sediment
unless the sediment really was anoxic
for example which is possible
something there's you know oxygen in the
upper water column but not on the bottom
and nothing could get down there
so i can't rule out the possibility that
these things are much deeper in time
but that's where the trace fossils
become strangely important even though
we have no idea what the hell made them
in detail
okay so
um
just wrapping up
developmental systems must have been
evolved at least rudimentary form
unless the ecology the evolution of
behaviors and morphologies of ecological
interaction that the latent potential
for morphological innovation in the
genome was released
and that gives the suddenness
but it still takes roughly 10 million
years but evolution of invasion of land
took about that long the radiation of
mammals after the cretaceous takes about
that long so it seems to take about 10
million years for major evolution
radiations to occur
so the approach is unashamedly
ecological and adaptationist in nature
and i put that up because i grew up at a
stage when golden lewington
basically
said you couldn't say this
so it's taken me a while to shed that
part of my training
no new genetic mechanism is required to
explain the camera explosion
it suggests if we were to rerun the
history of life we might get
morphological forms not all that
different from what we see in the fossil
record so to my mind i view evolution as
an engineering problem i've got
construction rules i've got a set of
tasks that those rules have to make an
organism to satisfy and there will be a
set of solutions
and evolution solves the np-hard problem
exploring that fitness landscape circa
10 million years
variation is like the jumping rule
selection is like the acceptance rule
and so it just so that's
i'm gonna get bashed here so i
you feel finished mammals didn't arise
multiple times and
reptiles didn't arise multiple times if
if it was inevitable in the sense
so let me go somewhere slightly
different it turns out that there are
mechanically four ways of being a
carnivore if you're a large vertebrate
you can be a hyper carnivore eating
solely meat you can be a bone cracker
like a hyena
you can be an omnivore like a dog where
the molar has both a cutting blade and a
grinding surface or you can be like a
bear that only has grinding surfaces
so in the dentition one of those four
engineering solutions it turns out that
today the hyper carnivores are the big
cats lions tigers cheetahs
go back 20 million years ago the hyper
carnivores were a dog group
go back 40 million years it was a
different dog group
so from an
eco-morphological point of view
hypercarnivory has evolved three times
twice in dogs and once in in the
carnivores
so
if you don't get too tied up with the
clay mammal reptile amphibian but you
look at the ecomorphology these things
do appear multiple times
so even though there are fewer genes
invented during the the tambourine
periods
uh it means
still be possible that those genes are
somehow more important in terms of
regulatory functions well so i think
most of the genes involved irregular
regulatory genes i don't think there's
that many more genes
i mean the vertebrate chordate genomes
got duplicated twice so there's there's
more genes now than there was in that
sense but i don't think that there's
been a huge change in gene numbers since
the cambridge explosion and most of the
genes are important are going to be
regulatory genes
right so
i guess that's sort of maybe a pushback
it's your second point here i mean it's
still
possible that
it's there were important regulatory
innovations that were needed during the
campaign period
to allow for that but not well it's
possible it's possible it's true coming
through explosion but in some like
there's a combinatorial explosion then
you could argue that that innovation has
to occur before the fighter diverged
from each other
because they all share that same
innovation whatever it is so you know
the invention of using micro rna is to
sort of really refine morphological
expression
so it doesn't exclude the possibility it
doesn't say it's not required it might
have happened
and that and that is still tricky
i think what happens is we get fooled by
the fact that the animal fire by eye
look utterly non-commensurate jellyfish
sea urchin and us but genetically
they're quite commensurate but basically
different variations of a theme
and that's what that's all i'm saying
there and there
there's one two three
but what's up yeah
so um
you say this is sort of um
unashamedly ecological
but then you know you
the the thing that you're talking about
with the morphogenesis and the um
development of
of plants i mean none of your rules
they're involved
ecology right i mean right so so i guess
what i'm saying so what i'd like to say
is that so steve gould and lewinton the
sand spaniels of san marco and the what
is it the
poverty of the adaptationist program or
something
um basically at least in paleontology
you couldn't even use the word
adaptation
uh for about a decade and a half at our
nationals and meetings and things like
that but variation is a two-step uh
evolution there's a two-step process
there's variation
and then this selection and i like a
modification of van vaden's
characterization of that
which is the filtering of the of
development by ecology
development's the variation part
ecology is the arena within which
selection occurs so i viewed within
evolution as the filtering of
development by ecology
so there's innovation at the
developmental level and there's a
developed set of developmental rules and
then there's the ecological part
and so this is unashamedly ecological
adaptations but obviously the
morphogenic space is the development
part of it it's just that i'm
questioning the usefulness of the whole
fitness landscape ideas since it doesn't
actually say anything about ecology
right because it's just this sort of
idea
you know you sort of need to know what's
out there
competing with you and predating on you
to know you know what the the sort of
landscape is so it's well such a static
landscape
so i've got a right so i've got a paper
in press which is specifically on the
evolution of fitness landscapes
and so the problem is that sewer right
and most people have a static fitness
landscape
and my feeling is for the most part they
are not static yeah and gabrielettes has
got this ridiculous thing where you know
his part of his justification is that
you can't go between peaks
all right it's ridiculous because in my
opinion what happens is that the damn
peaks move carrying the populations with
them so you don't actually have to have
morphological transformations by going
into fitness values you can just move
with a piece if you can keep up with it
so then what happens is what are the
modes of fitness landscape evolution one
of them you can increase the density of
peaks that's ecological you can add new
morphogenetic rules that's developmental
you can take a given rule and add more
variance to the adb cis abc system for
plant
uh
morphogenesis different angiosperms have
different b genes so you increase the
possibilities another one is you can
just move the peaks around that's going
to be an ecological change so the
invasion of birds into the air or whales
into the water has no fundamental
genetic innovation at all
the change in environment changes the
peaks
so i think when you think about the the
ways in which the landscape is going to
evolve you can start to identify given
specific examples when ecology matters
when development matters
so whether that's useful or not but
that's what i've been sort of going with
which i didn't
valleys are not the include
yes right
though you know
one thing that really strikes me in the
fossil record and again monty talked
about it um
yesterday is that stasis
um is pretty common in the fossil record
which tells me that things aren't moving
through the ridges to other peaks very
often so the peaks
peaks are real and so then it matters
what the scaling is of the ridges
and i know what that scaling looks like
but i think most of the time it's
effectively a valley
a game theoretic yeah
that that
organisms change each other's because
yeah
so all right so i modeled co-evolution
that's exactly right
right so you get escalation
bigger clause that's movement in space
means bigger shells my michelle's out
moving in their space so co-evolution or
evolution escalation would be sort of
movement of peaks so i'm not sure how
useful it is but i think as a i'm really
a morphologist
and so um you know the problem i have
with sewell right types landscapes or or
kaufman stuff or gabrielettes is it
never actively engages the phenotype of
a specific solvent
just reduces everything down to our
fitness which is you know and that's not
very useful to me as a paleontology and
a morphologist so that's where i'm
coming from that's my prejudice
we have one last question
yeah um yeah i'm sorry may i go back to
something you mentioned in the previous
talk what you ended with when you said
that
the beginning of life was easy and that
the rest of it is where the hard part
comes in so can can you try to reconcile
that to the usual new one or at least
that i've heard
you know the evolution of dna you know
how you get started it was the hard part
and then then of course you can you can
imagine
going from there
so the way the way i think about it is
in terms of waiting times
charles
so the question is
it sounds
the question the statement is that i'm
sort of reversing the the normal sense
where the really hard part is to
polymerize things like dna rna and make
life in the first instance and then once
you've done that it seems fairly easy to
get the rest of the stuff and i seem to
be saying the reverse that actually
getting lifestyle is pretty simple but
getting something like homo sapiens is
really really hard
um
and so
the way i think about it is in terms of
waiting times basically and so the
waiting time from when life could have
originated on earth the end of the heavy
bombardment and when it did looks like
it's fairly short
10 100 million years
relatively short where the waiting time
once you've got life to the emergence of
say the capacity to make telescopes
is four billion years
and even in the cambrian explosion which
takes well that takes four or three and
a half billion years to get to cambridge
explosion i can't even sniff yet
the invasion of land let alone
primates let alone humans
so it looks like these hard thresholds
to cross that take enormous parts of
geologic time now maybe what happens is
that it's actually really easy it's just
you've got to get the right boundary
conditions and then the transition is
simple
so that's the other alternative
incredibly long waiting times of nothing
happening
and then the change in the boundary
conditions and then it happens very
quickly
and so origin of sentience doesn't seem
to be quite like one of those
so so that's so that's the dilemma and i
don't know how to answer that problem
and it comes back again monty again
outlined in his talk you know
so what extent is evolution
fundamentally sort of dependent upon the
availability of the right variation
but we have to invent so many levels of
control before you get to us
and i think the invention of control is
the hard thing
you're going to regulate cells you've
got to make a urethra eukaryotic cell or
the cytoskeleton
mitochondria if you have the
mitochondria you've got the energy
source so you're screwed so how long
does that take
and then you've got to get obligate
metazoans and that seems like a bad
thing rather than a good thing so how
long does that take and then the cells
have to learn to talk to each other so
that they actually can produce
hundreds or thousands or millions of
cell lengths away something different
that's really quite staggering right
you know that you know my part of my
liver it has no idea that a bone is
developing there are neurons developing
there so you've got to develop that
system
um
okay we have to stop now
i'm sorry okay
thank you very much